-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tina Fey.
You sent me a very lovely text
that was both complimentary
and maybe a little concerned
after you saw "Day Drinking
with Seth and Lizzo."
-Yes.
I watched it, we all did,
and it was hilarious
and fantastic, and Lizzo
is the best, obviously.
But I texted you and Shoemaker
and said, like,
"But you don't really
drink all that, right?"
And Shoemaker wrote back,
"He does drink all of that,
and he actually drinks
more than that
and we have to cut it down
for air,
because the network is worried
it's irresponsible."
[ Laughter ]
And so then I went back
and I re-watched, like,
Ina Garten,
and I became concerned for you.
-Yeah.
-That's so much alcohol.
-I know, it's...
And I'm not getting any younger.
I really wear it for, like,
a full week.
-I was gonna say, 'cause
I wanted to say to you,
"Can I do an imitation of
what I imagine
your lovely spouse, Alexi,
must feel like
when you come home from
one of those?"
-I'll tell you how
accurate it is.
-Okay, 'cause I feel like,
if I were your wife
and you came home from
day drinking with Lizzo,
I would be like this.
I'd be like, "It was good?
Okay. No, th--
No, we don't want to
go out for subs."
[ Laughter ]
"No, the kids ate.
Okay.
Wow."
[ Laughter ]
"Either brush your teeth
or go to bed."
[ Laughter ]
Is it that kind of a...?
-And I will tell you that
two back,
she said, "I have an idea.
I think you, when it's over,
I think you should stay
at a nearby hotel."
[ Laughter ]
-I actually sort of assumed
that maybe you did.
-She was like, "Why don't you
let yourself off the hook
for a night?"
-Yeah.
Instead of coming back
and being like,
"Oh, she was so funny?
Great."
-Yeah, yeah.
She loves hearing --
She loves me being really drunk,
sort of like just
singing the praises
of a pop star.
-Oh, of Rihanna, yeah.
-"Rihanna's so real!"
-I bet. She's so real.
-She's so happy.
That was her happiest day.
[ Laughter ]
When we were texting,
when you wrote me that,
I was like, "Where are you?"
And you were in London,
working on a movie
with Kenneth Branagh.
-Yes!
-That's amazing.
-It's crazy, right?
So yeah, I got to go to London
for three months
and work on this movie called
"A Haunting in Venice."
Which -- I'll come back
when it comes out.
I'll tell you about it then.
-Okay, okay.
-But I loved getting a chance
to live in London
and come back, I'm insufferable.
I say things like
"jacket potato" now.
-Oh, wow. That's a good one.
You've got to really be there
for like --
-"Do you have a jacket potato?"
What?
It's so nice there.
Oh, my gosh, the subway system
is like -- mm! -- stab-free.
-Oh, that's nice.
You don't miss it a little bit?
You don't miss the thrill
of like,
is today the day I get stabbed?
-Yeah, I don't miss the,
like, "Serpico" vibe, no.
You can buy wine
in the grocery store.
Also everything has
adorable names.
Every product has like,
everything's cute.
So you'll be like,
"Can I just get some
fizzy nobblers?
They're tampons, right?
The fizzy nobblers."
[ Laughter ]
"And the gabbledy-gos?
The suppositories for when
you're constipated, yes."
Everything's just charming.
-Those are the gabbeldy-gos?
-Yeah, gabbeldy-gos.
-Oh, that's helpful to know.
-Yeah, if you get there,
you want to get gabbeldy-gorps,
'cause you've traveled.
-'Cause you know how I am
when I fly.
-You don't.
-I need them like, immediately.
-But it was delightful,
and I'm sure you know from your
one night drunk in the hotel,
being away from your family
is wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
It's wonderful.
-The only thing that's better
than me being in a hotel
a block away,
being away from your family
in a different timezone?
And you gotta be like,
"I tried to call.
You were asleep."
-Yes!
My husband would call me
and be like,
"Both dogs have diarrhea,"
and I'd be like,
"Oh, it's night time here.
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry."
And then they got to come
to London for Christmas,
which was great.
-Perfect.
-And we all had
a wonderful time,
but I felt like a person
who had
escaped a cult and then was
pulled back into that cult.
-That scene where the cult
find you.
-Yes, where like, the weird guy
in shorts comes to you and says,
"Hey, you've really forgotten
your belief system.
Remember, what we believe here
is that you gain value
in your life by picking up
our wet towels."
[ Laughter ]
"This is who you are.
Look, look how many shoes
we brought."
[ Laughter ]
-We're very happy
you went back.
-And I was like, "You're right,
you guys are probably right."
And then I came home.
-Well, we're very happy
to have you back in the city.
-Thank you.
-Last thing before you go,
there's gonna be a new season
of "Girls5eva" on Netflix,
which is really exciting.
-Yes! Very excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
Seasons 1 and 2 are still
available on Peacock,
our friends at Peacock
have those.
If you are a jacket potato
in the UK,
you can see 1 and 2 on Netflix.
-That's great.
-Elsewhere in the world.
And then Season 3's gonna be
on Netflix.
We're starting shooting soon.
I'm super excited.
Meredith Scardino is the
funniest person in the world.
And of course, Paula Pell,
Sara Bareilles, Rene Goldsberry,
Busy Phillips.
-That's great.
It's a great cast.
It's a great show.
So happy to have you here.
Congratulations on the tour!
-Thank you guys!
-Sold out! Tina Fey.
For more information
on Restless Leg Tour,
go to TinaAmyTour.com
to find out it's too late
to get tickets.
We'll be right back
with Nate Bargatze.